let's go to our next caller from the 905
area code caller from 905 go ahead
hi David my name is hasher I'm actually
calling from Toronto Canada
oh good okay that's a lot yeah so what I
wanted to talk about was what do you
think of the rise of all these guys
coming under the guise of classical
liberalism but really it's just like
it's just another coke brother backed
think-tank right-wing propaganda outlet
I'm very very interested in propaganda
read a little bit of Noam Chomsky
manufactured consent it's just really
perplexing to me because I went to the
same school where Jordan Peterson had
his famous video right and I was right
there in front of him and it was just
very very weird I mean a couple
different things number there's two
different elements of this there are the
people who are making a lot of money by
saying they are classical liberals or
they are sort of the real liberals or
what you you know all the different
iterations I don't have to tell you
about it now sure but there's people who
are doing it because it's a really great
character to make money and there's a
lot of money to be made on it with
sponsorships and speaking gigs and all
these different things right that's from
the point of view of the hosts of
programs journalists whatever the other
side of it is the individuals who are
being bamboozled by it into thinking
that hey I sort of think about myself as
open-minded but I really don't like
sjw's or language policing and I like
calling people Cox
so I think on a classical liberal or
something like that classical liberalism
is we've exposed it it's a pretty damn
conservative ideology with a very
specific set of principles that have
some leeway of course like any set of
principles progressivism is is a
spectrum and conservatism classical
liberalism whatever but you know I
actually understand it I don't respect
it but I understand the people who are
doing the I'm a classical liberal thing
as positioning to grow their following
and their audience and their income but
the problem I have with it is that
they're not doing it in an echo chamber
and there's a lot of people that are
being bamboozled into saying hey I'm a
classical liberal - yeah because this
like take the sample this jordan
peterson guy
always saying science does science that
I mean he's a very wise person I went to
the school and I I did the neuroscience
program there we never ever look at
anything he had ever to say and we he
doesn't even talk about any real science
this the thing about gender as he comes
he's a climate change denier you see his
tweets it's just very very interesting
yeah I don't know anything about that
part but I'll look into him more yeah I
share your concern and I really
appreciate the call thank you very much
I really like the show thank you for
having thanks my pleasure